come here come here
honey birthday things are heating up for
Brody Jenner and Josie Canseco and only
et is taking you inside his 36th
birthday bash Miley Cyrus and Brody's ex
Kaitlyn also helped him celebrate but
more on that in just a minute
[Music]
check out the scene inside LA's warwick
nightclub last night there's brodie
celebrating his birthday and that blonde
that's Josie eyewitnesses tell eg the
pair was kissing in front of everyone
throughout the night and seemed very
comfortable with each other
rody also shared this video of the pair
in the car ok so all of this comes just
weeks after Brody and Kaitlynn split
she's seemingly dating Miley now and get
this they sent Brody a joint birthday
gift Miley and Caitlyn you guys really
stepped it up on this one you know my
favorite company of all time
we got the birthday card attached to the
weed bouquet look at this I have never
seen one of these in my entire life
oh my god it's the curse - happy
birthday to me
and yeah check out the card from Miley
and Kaitlyn quote Brody we'd like to
wish you a happy birthday
love you okay then et has learned the
gift cost around $1,000 and that Miley
put the request in a few days ago she
also happens to be an investor in the
company
[Music]
alright guys what do you make of all of
this are you surprised Brody Kaelin and
Miley all seemingly moved on so fast let
me know and for all the latest on the
story keep it locked to all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krause and bye
for now